when you work out your shit now mm-hmm
I've seen you at the comedy store but
only once where do you work out your
shit I like to go to random comedy clubs
you know I think I'll go to New York
first New York has always been a home
when it comes to building putting some
structure within a set that you know how
to figure out once I got a skeleton of
what I want to do I'll just go to West
Palm I love that comedy club The Improv
down there it's great I'll stay for two
weeks
Oh real and just go and run through some
jokes I'll go to Utah I'll go to Denver
whoo Doodlebug wiseguys yeah yeah yeah
I'll go to comedy clubs just random
comedy clubs that you would expect to
see me yet but I'll do a hell of a run
and the goal is to get out of there with
just a foundation it's not to have a
complete set I just want to get a
foundation so when I'm done getting the
foundation then I'll do a little comedy
club run I'll do a full comedy club run
where I'll just put two or three months
in and it's come to club comedy club
comedy club and I'm doing seven shows a
weekend and people are shocked that I'm
there and that I'm doing it but you know
that's my that's my gym that's how I
work and I end up leaving that period of
time with a complete set after the first
three or four months that I spent
now after that comedy club three or four
months on that run then I take it to
like a small theater I see what my
laughter feels like in a small theater
and I do little run in small theaters
and then when I finally feel like it's
at a point where I'm getting the the
laugh consistently and the punchlines
are working and I flipped it back
frontwards forward every direction and
my story is a real roller coaster and it
has an ending where I feel like we get
off the roller coaster and we're happy
and you don't feel like you were there
for an hour
mmm then when I go test it out with
Irina and if the arena if the Laster
sounds the way it's supposed to then I
say okay I'm ready if it doesn't then
I'll go back to small theaters and then
I'll go to an arena again so not to that
arena sounds the way it's supposed to do
I say I'm going on tour so sometimes it
takes me about a year a year and three
months here in four months you know
people don't say how hard it is to
develop
an hour of stand-up material if you act
like you just turn on a new hour it's
it's an hour to get to an hour you're
going through four to five hours of
bullshit that you thought was funny yeah
to come up to that hour that you finally
say this is gonna be the representation
of me this year yeah it's a lot for me
to do that especially at this level you
know well especially while you're always
doing movies and you're always busy with
a bunch of other stuff to stuff yourself
yeah you don't take any breaks white or
I actually you know when I'm touring if
there's a movie I make the movie
schedule around the torso my shooting
days will go Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday rap Thursday maybe ever show
Thursday night and then I'm going
Thursday Friday Saturday sometimes no
show Sunday sometimes show Sunday
depending on what the work schedule and
the workload for the following week
would look like so I'm implementing that
in so when I say I'm out I'm out I'm
gone yeah so I've knocked that movie out
in two months and then when I'm not that
tour schedule shifts so the Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday dedicated the
family dedicated to an office everything
then those weekends are torn but that's
or last for a year and a half I mean
this year we did 157 shows on my
irresponsible tour 157 show before you
decided to put it on the Netflix special
yeah we did the Netflix the taping I
think I did it three weeks before we
were done so we probably had 143 shows
oh wow
then I taped it and finish the tour did
you always have this kind of structure
like when did you how did you design
this thought-out individual yeah I mean
thought-out individual it's not random
no everything is planned if you look at
all my stand-up specials there's a
two-year gap in between them so the
two-year gap is because at the end of
that second year my new special should
be coming out when a new special should
be coming out I'm now focusing on what
the next special is going to be so that
first year is all development like right
now I'm off I'm not touring but now I'm
mentally in the gym and throwing all the
old stuff that I talked about a way
that's now thrown out can't repeat it
can't say
now it's talking about what the new
version of myself is going to be what do
I want the conversation to be and what's
my thinking and just taking notes so
eventually now I'm gonna start just
popping up a random comedy clubs and
trying to figure out what the next thing
is so by mid mid 20
I'll probably be doing comedy clubs by
the end of 20 I have a full fledge
concept of that new hour and by the
beginning of 21 I should be ready to go
out with my new hour hmm end of 21 film
my new our mid 22 that hour would come
out that seems like a schedule a lot of
people are doing now the 2-year schedule
it's a perfect get yeah that's hard dude
I know louis c.k did a year every year
and George Carlin did every year but I
think even he said really wasn't the
right way that's tough
a year stuff yeah I mean that's a that's
a shout-out to those that can't do it I
think that's amazing
I think just for everything that I have
going on and all of the different things
that my hands are in within the brand
the business I need to make sure that
I'm giving a hundred percent change
those things so they have the highest
opportunity to be successful right if
I'm trying to cheat it then it's gonna
show you know it's not gonna come out to
the best of my ability and with that
stand up you got a you got a fucking
magnifying glass on you you know you're
always being judged off of what you did
at one point just like a musician you're
always judged off of the album that
everybody thought was whatever so the
biggest thing for an entertainer artists
whatever your craft is is creation how
you recreating yourself how are you
constantly showing that you're growing